well let's return to the outcry from
passengers as the new year brings new
higher prices on the railways the
overall rise will AB strip the increase
set by the government leading unions to
accuse private train companies of
milking the system will I'm join from
central london by kat Hobbs director of
the campaign group we own it thanks very
much for joining us cat so is this
what's happening here is this private
companies just trying to strip
passengers for all that they've got I'm
afraid I think that's exactly what's
happening what we're seeing is train
fares are rising yet again above
inflation and above wages and passengers
really can't deal with them anymore
increases so I think you know really the
the privatized rail system isn't working
here but isn't isn't this all about a
rebalancing though cat that at the
moment what we have is that the general
taxpayer who may or may not use the
train system is having to pay a lot more
into the system to keep it going and
what the government is trying to do is
shift that onto the people that actually
use the service so they are paying a
greater proportion of it that makes
sense surely well that's what the
government is saying but the truth is
that the cost of running the railway has
increased massively since privatisation
and that cost is being directly passed
on to passengers what we know is that
railways in other countries are the
European countries like France and
Germany are much much cheaper the
overall system is cheaper it's more
efficient and that means that passengers
pay less in this country we're paying
sometimes double for the ticket prices
of other European countries precisely
because our system is so inefficient but
I usually are you sympathetic to it to
the point though that the rail delivery
group and the government are making it
that there has been a systemic under
investment in the railway network for
four years and we're trying now to build
that back up again the rail delivery
group saying ninety-seven percent of
every pound of what you pay for your
ticket goes to improve services well
exactly so where does the other three
percent go that goes straight into
shareholders pockets and that's not to
mention all of the inefficiency and the
wastefulness that happens because we
have a fragmented train system you know
you don't know who's running your train
versus who's running the track it should
all be in one system run as a
all network that would make a lot more
sense and what we know is that people
think that privatization has failed
fifty-eight percent of people think it's
failed only one percent of people think
it's a complete success and that just
shows how passengers are so angry about
this that they really need change to
happen I think it's very disingenuous of
the government and the train companies
to try to pretend that privatization has
worked when passengers are seeing
overcrowded trains hi affairs that just
keep on increasing it clearly isn't
working and so would you like to see
water Jeremy Corbyn is is proposing and
that is just to realization of the
entire system so kind of the network as
well as the operators yeah I think
that's exactly right but we don't need
to talk about renal izing we can talk
about the public ownership ownership of
the future actually being much better
than what we've had in the past but it
should be run for passengers not for
profits and that can be done just by
bringing in train contracts as they come
up for renewal but we remember or some
of us remember the days of national rail
and they were hardly the glory days of
the railway network were they well
that's because at that time the
government wasn't actually investing in
the rail network as it needed to but as
I say in the future if we have the
investment and it's not going into train
companies shareholder profits but it's
actually going back into the rail
network that could be a much better
system so what are you calling for the
government to do I mean obviously
they're not going to re nationalize so
so what would you like to see from the
government now well the government is
highly ideological about this it's
completely committed to the idea that
private train companies are the right
people to be running the railway but
actually we know that there isn't really
a market you know you don't get any
choice about what train you get on so
that doesn't really work but they'll
keep on reading that line what we need
to do is show that the public isn't
isn't supporting that the public wants
to see public ownership of the railways
and we need to show that that's
practical because it's actually happened
before we've seen public ownership of
the railways on the east coast line and
that worked really really well Ted Hobbs
director of the campaign group we own it
thank you very much indeed for joining
us